we grow I was born in Starkville
Mississippi I grew up a young countryman
gas and at two three years old I hunted
I fished I did they're climbing the
trees around the horses the whole nine
you're I'm talking about from from
running through berry bushes to to
picking picking out out of the garden
you know I didn't chop a lot of rows
since I was young man and I've been
through a whole lot and then in the
years that I didn't grew up man
especially coming from a country from
country to the city I came out to LA and
79 79 I was 19 years old at 19 years old
right then South Central
yes indeed I'm from Harlem Creek that
sound better 19 the sale stayed over
there for 39 years
my first attempted murder was 19 years
old I was here six months six months and
they gave me a gun
job to go outside a gun somebody now and
I think I was as scared as the gun was
yeah that 19 years old so you're not
thinking about going to kill nobody but
during that time either you did them
what they did to your own your home gang
I'm saying it was like it was like
turning your back on but you know I
yeah what I did and at 19 and 20 years
old I did another 10 but you know the
fighting and the stabbing and the
curtain then all these scores that I got
on my buddy before I was 21 years old
had got shot twice
Noah I didn't get close never got caught
[Music]
nose changing by Jesus birth because
you're both pants
normal childhood country boy going to
church every Sunday come back to here to
be violent and it turned me into that
person that I didn't really want to be
but because I had done this game that's
what it was yeah so no other option that
wasn't happen
I think out of my head after there 30
years I've been around maybe know to hit
Stuart's that's it one to college you
know I'm saying because everything else
was speak nuts you know he was raised in
the streets
and I was raised in the streets so back
to you
twenty-one years old man I went on a I
went on a drive by and it was women and
kids to where the point my little home
boys didn't care but I did because I
could not kill these old women are no
kids because they're telling people that
did nothing to me
yeah I'm saying and I got disciplined
for that couldn't forgot she met many
people I got really disciplined to the
point where I was in the hospital for
five days yes they are they are
treacherous when it come to to uphold
and yo-yo place in a gang
especially if you and one of the ones I
come from you know and 22 23 years old I
was in Pelican Bay Pelican Bay for
assault with a deadly weapon which was
the iron pipe sure one of my enemies
here from from from 20s but the thing
about it he didn't die but you know he
came close and being that I was so young
my first time in prison they scared me
to death
because Pelican Bay was the worst prison
and in California and at the age of 24
years old man it was like it was like he
was he was being reborn all again
because he was told when the heat when
the [ __ ] when they move when they sleep
and I wasn't used to that so about nine
months into Pelican Bay I caught another
shooter my 13 wants you they sent me
some from Pelican Bay to croaker
korkin therefore you only come out of
your cell for one hour day so I did
these 13 13 months for one day I like
one thing out of a week and you pick the
day your showers came to your cell your
food came to your cell your milk in
yourself
everything came to yourself and when we
used to go outside it was a lot of
tension between the blacks and the mess
why because of the seals they used to
bet on that they're just that the CEO
the correctional used to bet who would
win these fights between the black
sending messages until one person got
killed and they found out about it they
blew up in their face because they would
save me fast and they would put me in a
cave and five minutes later taken five
essays and for the same case now what's
the first my first mission was to get
closer to the door and hit the first one
coming in because I it was no other
alternative Hispanics
yes gang members and back then you had
some gang members dead as friends that
would kill a black before they would
either eat a piece of bread believe me
and so when I got out of it when I got
out of cooking how the crook of shoes I
came home back downtown homeless today
age of 24 years old out here on these
streets people manipulate you they they
try to take over your mind they try to
take over anything that you got but me
being raised the way I was raised I'm a
very strong person to the point where I
see through a whole lot of the bullcrap
that they was they was break
and two years down here sir I got I got
shot right here
I was dancing I was dancing on the
sidewalk me and three girls and the same
dude that I hit with this pipe it's the
one that shot he tried to shoot me in my
back I know that's what he's very shy
doing paralyzed because uh I heard
through the grapevine that he didn't
want me to die he just wanted me to be
paralyzed so where I could roll around a
nutshell the rest of my life but because
of one of the ladies seeing behind me
told me he had a gun I turned and
therefore it hit me here and still in
the slide so well cuz it was a 45 we
were it would have really really told me
yet after that that's what that gun shot
me I got into smoking crack cocaine very
very very him I'm talking about at least
a half ounce to an ounce a day that's
maybe three to four hundred dollars a
day and and I'm to like this would I
would be up for seven eight nine ten
days at a time drinking smoking running
around I would go I would go 100 miles
in a five-block baby five block radius I
would go through them five blocks in
them days man a hundred miles and today
it's back and forth on that crack be
crack led me to going to prison I went
back to prison for burglary a
residential burglary this was in 1992 I
ended back in court beyond six months
into cooking we had a riot
blacks against domestic it was it was 29
people that had to be airlifted from
Corcoran chute to the hospital because
there was a lot of staffing and you know
when you imprison back then in them
times man it wasn't no fighting and you
know that's it it was a lot of people
getting stabbed and thank God I wasn't
one of them but you know I I get out
again get out of prison back downtown
back downtown oh I'm gonna go to me a
program I'm gonna do the right thing go
to a program stay maybe estimate eight
days I'm back on the street back with
the same routine same people that's why
I said hey if you do the same thing over
and over you don't get the same results
so I've been followed every nine then
try a little bit different but like I
tell people you did if I'm not ready
okay nobody make me ready just stop
using drugs I've been using drugs since
I was 13 years old I still use drugs
Saturday I'm 59 years old and I know I
look known looking because penitentiary
preserves you believe me and Ryland did
25 years of my life in prison
I haven't been to 13 princesses and
that's bad to say but when you gain back
Jane Banga led me to a life of misery
and 96 96 hours
I was I was sure I didn't care I didn't
care about nothing or nobody
I was smoking crack and shine together
which was up hug our deadly mixer I mean
deadly to where the crack put me in a
happy mood to shine put me in a bad mood
and I just saw him take over the good
move now I'm in a bad mood now I'm gonna
fight everybody I want to kill everybody
and they're there to prison after prison
time at the prison turn because your
life I hear on the streets their
survival I mean real survival cuz you
could be somewhere sleep sir and
somebody can come up cook joke though
it's always one person I hear watching
everybody
but believe me somebody's watching that
if you doing drugs if you can these
these nice bikes if you got these nice
clothes you're working for this drug
dealer people are watching and they have
to get what you get one way or another
get you out the way I'll get it from you
you know I'm fans and we say have tried
sir I've been so paranoid out here to
where I know I could hear somebody
talking on trouble about me four blocks
away and that's impossible but the drugs
had me - strung out to where I thought I
heard people talking about 1998-99 I
came back I went to prison again for I
think it was failure to report they gave
me two years so I've been at the 98 sir
mark my time with they're going into
life
like probation violation 16 months two
years three years I'm right back out in
12 months 13 months and it was the same
thing to the point where I really wanted
to go back home but then again I hadn't
had met so many people that had that
this was my family I considered it as my
family and in Los Angeles California and
my people used to tell me all the time
yeah you should call them when are you
coming home she'll your people oh I'm
come next month next month BD symbol
from Jenny where I'm telling them come
on January December they called me I
still in California simply because I got
stuck on in his life and it's like
something in here is telling me that hey
you have nothing worth I know bills you
got to worry about paying on mortgage no
lights no gas no ministry so who can
charge you anything so that's been my
lifestyle it's 2000 almost went to jail
for the rest of my life and I caught a
murder what a great job for murder
manslaughter
I'd be if I did from 2000 to 2010 my
first prison was CRC narco
see I see not so I called two years
first six months I was there because the
dude thought I was somebody else
and he just really wanted to kill me I
really wanted to mess me up because he
said I had killed somebody in this town
then notice dude from Allen but he
constantly picked up so one day we got
in it into the bathroom and I stabbed
him with a with a sheet of tile sheet of
broken tile in the neck and it's
juggling and almost caught all our
in-house murder and I was murdered
cursor here in 30 years off the top you
don't have answers but but because the
man they living I guess 70 days and he
died and went from murder to
manslaughter involuntary manslaughter I
got out of got out of prison in 2010
from 2000-2010
2010 I got out came back to the streets
no home no family no kids
all had nothing worried about the lift
$200 they gave me I a was gone before
the next one next morning I couldn't buy
a cup of coffee and a doughnut but you
know what I was still like him I was
still doing what I was doing out here
robbing stealing no never had to do to
survive and just some stop me
2011 I stopped gaming because I was
tired I was getting old and got shot too
many time bullets hurt real bad
believe me they hurt and because I
stopped game ringing I got into I got
into 35 stirred in my homeboys has to
jump me up do you know lining it up for
30 people 30 young dudes to fight in one
day and one day I love I love my front
chief I had black eyes over black eyes
but because I stood my ground I thought
everybody
they let me up 2012 I got I got a got
out of hard and clip I stopped banging I
still represented her but I don't back
some of my little homeboys are down here
right now today and they see me and they
they acknowledge they accept that on I
don't no longer gangbang but I'm a gang
member
yeah they took all of that sir to get
out of came back it's easy to get in but
it's hell to get out you have to you
have to almost lose your life to get out
of game 2013 I caught another assault
with a deadly weapon right down here on
6th and st. Jesus dude tried to rob and
I hit him with a bat
I hit a minute tip over the back
and that was one of the worst days of my
life
he didn't meant that bad because you
know I I brain matter in the whole thing
sirs I've cracked his skull wide open
downtown sir in the middle of six and
st. you mean didn't care
Jim care at all but my little homeboy
scoop me up Joe mill way I got lucky
because there's nobody telling because I
had that much clout to where I was
selling that much dope and I was giving
that much double weight to the people
that Devils around me that smoke I had a
god that front of me he fronted me like
three ounces of dope a day and all he
wanted was $300
I'll make 300 out of a half ounce of
them so therefore he was giving me like
a bushel of great compared to one prune
and I took that and I ran with it sir
and I was I was getting high on top of
high around 2010 I mean 2015 I kind of
really really calm down and wounded I
don't want to realize that I was moving
too fast
and I did I met a young lady we kicked
it we kicked it and she got pregnant she
got pregnant
I went to jail but not me knowing that
she was pregnant in 2006 I went to jail
mm love was born October 7 2006 I'll
stay around April 2007 I got uh it was
just for a violation I was in a program
I was in the wine going I had been in
the wine going maybe five months and my
Mike my case manager came up said that I
had a I had a visit
I said Alan visit all my people is in
Mississippi so how can I have a visit
from somebody so I go downstairs and
there's this girl that I had sex with
one time ended up being 12 she shops
were up years old from one time having
sex with this lady I have a 12 year old
daughter named love
right today sir my daughter's my
daughter she comes now and she no I I
don't hold nothing back from her you
know I'm saying nothing at all and she
told me out of all my dad when you get
when you ready you gonna stop I said
he's I'm gonna stop and keep on living
oh my god which I'm not scared to do
even one you know I'm saying my baby my
baby is I don't know if she got the old
soul enough but she then told me a lot
from from the age of a tutorial about
this life about being the just life in
general
my baby mama can't stand but I don't
know what she she took she used to take
my daughter places that she knew I
couldn't come out because I won't roll
pin lickin leave for two mile radius you
leave for the moderators you going back
to prison at big kitchen so therefore
man I just been in and out enough and
today I'm I'm happy to say that I'm not
on probation or parole as of 2019 and
I'm I'm going to get my housing I am
going through to get my mind my dental
I'm going through to get everything it's
it's free my eyes have opened
I still get hot yes every day but when
the appointments come oh I got a log
down believe me and I haven't missed an
appointment since I've been been out
this last six months so
therefore I was that was my life I hear
on these streets
it wasn't good and it wasn't bad but it
was alright I'm still here it's just an
answer not a problem not a problem
you